he's rich ties into the NFL Network the
Rich Eisen show on DirecTV the audience
network that follows this show go to
nfl.com slash run Rich run click on the
donate page to donate whatever you can
to st. Jude's Research Hospital every
dollar raised goes to st. Jude and rich
raises money when he runs his 40-yard
dash and that will be revealed later
today around two o'clock we caught up
with Richie Rich before his hosting
duties today on the NFL Network and I
asked him how did Bill Belichick end up
in the broadcast booth that's amazing
well Bella checking me out go way back I
mean I don't know if you're aware about
mike Mayock
football life but he was the 260 fifth
pick of the 1981 NFL Draft by the
Steelers and walked in is a bright eyed
kid from Boston College and saw
basically you know the entire Steel
Curtain Steelers at the end of their
career is like the Night at the Museum
all the busts came alive and they were
in his locker room and he he didn't last
there he got cut and he played at the
CFL for one year and then the Giants in
1982 picked him up and he's just like
everybody who's trying to break in the
NFL Mack was a special team player and
his coaches special teams coach was a
coach named Bill Belichick and he goes
oh so you just do the math back to 1982
with Bill and you know I don't know if
I'm telling any tales out of school but
you know a lot of a lot of evaluators
pick Mike's brain and I would prefer to
say Bella checks one of them over the
years and so bill just strolled into the
booth I mean I'm ready to talk to Mike
in a commercial break I'm showing him
you know something I'm on my phone and
all of a sudden he's not paying
attention he's looking over my shoulder
he goes hey coach they turn around it's
you know the guy with five Lombardi's
and they're chit-chatting and I'm
chit-chatting with him but now it's time
to go back to the to the to the
broadcast or back out of commercial
break I'm putting my headset on and
Mike's still talking to to bill and many
stuffs going on all of a sudden Willie
McGinest is on the field so nice
tell them you never guess who's here
Mayock now has his headset back on at
this point and for the first couple of
minutes of that segment we were relating
what what bill was saying to Willie on
the field through our microphones which
isn't the best thing and as you would
imagine Dan our producers in the truck
or screaming put the headset on him you
know
but Mayock and I talked about this
afterwards we both felt the same things
like look you know we want coaches
around here at the combine to feel free
to just come in and just stop by and say
hello or say whatever they want to say
drop some information if they want to or
not but just feel free to come in and
out we don't want them to think that
every time they walk in we're gonna try
to throw a headset on them so we didn't
do that and at one point it just became
apparent to us that okay I think he
really wanted to talk to him again so I
did what few people are in there you
know lives are basically do which is
hand their own headset to Bill Belichick
and then also off the segment went well
he was a little passive-aggressive there
wanting to get in a couple of digs at
the Colts which I thought was pretty
funny it was like a private conversation
with him and Willie like yeah I remember
they were throwing stuff at me and
remember that fourth down and two and
remember well that one but that one was
not a good moment for him I mean that
was like a one of those self-deprecating
Belichick moments that you don't really
hear very often you know and that was
one of the neat things and as soon as
you know he left it's Mayock saying I
mean you know what he wishes that more
fans would get to see that side of
Belichick which is you know a little bit
of an edge about himself and in a sense
of humor and you know for two and a half
three minutes that was it was just neat
it was completely and that was the best
part about it was obvious that it was
not planned it came out of nowhere and
and he you know had a nice wewe
eavesdropped I think we we live when
John Ross gets ready for the 40 and then
he's done with the 40 does it feel or I
mean is there a sense that you just saw
something a little different aside from
seeing the clock but is the reaction
does it tell you if you didn't have a
clock up there or what people just saw
well it's interesting that you'd say
that because of all the 40 stand
all of them for this year he even last
the year before our running clock did
not run on him it was the one time that
there was a malfunction and it was on
John Ross so we actually did have to do
what we just passed which is to assume
or wonder or think did we just see
something that we do believe looked
pretty damn fast and sure enough then
the time for tutu popped up but Steve
Smith recently retired Steve Smith is
part of our crew here now and he said he
very Nostradamus like we went to him on
the field because he was a woman around
with the water sleepers for the
broadcast that day he said you know I
was watching John Ross warm up and the
way that he was coming out of his stance
was faster than anybody I've seen here
or in a long time he goes I think he's
gonna run a really long time so I said
should see j2k be sitting up in his seat
right now and he goes he I think he
should and then boom that happened and
we waited about a half an hour for the
official time and it came back that the
four two two stuck and you know that was
that was amazing the kid kid should have
done what Deon did everyone was saying
which is back in the day which is run
you're 40 and run out the tunnel and
into a waiting car and go to the airport
he does not do that but he didn't work
out he said in effect he did that
he's Rich Eisen the NFL Network they're
continuing their coverage of the NFL
Combine by the way go to nfl.com slash
run rich run click on the donate button
you can donate whatever you would like
to be st. Jude's Children's Research
Hospital that rich has been a strong
proponent of been an active in that
charity for a long time every dollar
raised goes to st. Jude and by the way
rich is running his he's run his 40 I
believe is that right and then you
reveal it's okay
okay so today at 2:00 2:00 Eastern on
the animal Network that you have around
manage it depends on how the skills go
could be quarter to two and okay this
year I was particularly excited on earth
you because you're probably on the air
Friday when Damien mama the offensive
lineman is
of USC ran a five eight four which means
all I had to do is just shave off one
tenth of a second and I would actually
finally beat a player at the combine I
called it my pace car then and my pace
car and we reveal we reveal that and
what won't be pretty though is mysamma
cam of my forty over John Ross I I'm
just hoping that I'm by the five yard
line before Ross's out of the screen
which may not be the case to be very
honest with you the final item here and
it's troubling we spend some time in
this already yeah
how does Mitch try Biscay go to Mitchell
try Biscay was last time you were Daniel
my mom time only with my mom I was
always in trouble like I would think if
it's true Biscay threw an interception
it would be well whatever his middle
name is you'd have to ingest middle name
Mitchell Lane true Biscay get over here
my favorite tweet I saw in response to
that it was uh was uh she was shefter
tweeted out that Mister Biscay was now
all to call him Mitchell and somebody
retweeted that and said lightened up
Francis let me stripes mention that's my
stuff you touch my stuff I don't know I
mean but it did take Mayock at least an
hour to get that out of his system you
can call him Mitch and I kept looking at
him and he rolled his eyes at me it's
only mike Mayock can it's not joseph
montana Daniel Moreno or Jonathan Lane
it is true I do remember when I was
filling out my my labels of my
three-quarter-inch resume reels trying
to get a job in our business Stan I made
a very specific decision because I was
Richard growing up my entire life and I
just thought there's no there's no
sportscasters named Richard and I wasn't
gonna go the dick route dan so I just
went rich and and that that has stuck
but my mom still does slip into calling
me Richard every now and then I call you
very very rich Eisen thank you very much
Dan I appreciate that
we can't wait today for the unveiling of
Rich's forty
and if you're taking the under at 5.83
that what it is is that what it is
oh no under the under of Damien yes yeah
yeah that's it yeah mom is a pace car
yes a pace car yeah
I don't want to give anything away of
course not I came right away mama said
knock you out
thank you rich see bud dban Rich Eisen
running his 40 today later on Paulie
you're giving me stink face rich when
you brought up the 40 he didn't sound
like his usual jovial confident self I
have the feeling it didn't go great and
comparing the comparison to past years
based on his tone unless he's
sandbagging us well wasn't his gold just
to break six yeah that's a big leap to
go under six to five point eight three
so he can beat somebody at the combine
is its rich gonna be in the picture with
John Ross when they go side-by-side
they're not for long
yeah you know it'll be maybe it's like
the roadrunner the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience